okay we have some friends on the right
and some friends on the left that are
really missing the mark on a story about
Mitt Romney and : powell and potentially
george w bush not supporting Trump in
the upcoming election so here's what's
going on in the last 24 hours there have
been reports and interviews that former
Republican president george w bush
current Republican senator mitt romney
lifelong republican : powell and some
others will not be supporting the
re-election of donald trump now it's
important to understand that that
doesn't mean they're necessarily voting
for Joe Biden we'll get to that in a
second
the reactions from the right have been
completely predictable these are loser
triggered Republicans who are either
jealous of Trump success or mad that
Trump doesn't listen to them or they
have personal grudges Don jr. tweeted
who cares that he actors that who gives
a you know what that I think it's :
Powell or Mitt Romney isn't going to be
supporting Trump sort of like these are
losers we don't care about them they're
not even really Republicans as far as
we're concerned predictable response
from the right I don't care but sadly
I'm seeing some really bad takes on this
from some people on the left and they're
mostly coming from the slice of the left
that is Berlant Lee virulent Lee
irrationally anti Joe Biden I've started
hearing from people on the left stuff
like David the reason Romney and :
Powell and maybe Bush aren't supporting
Trump is because Biden is so far right
that they are just more aligned with
Biden's politics they're Republicans and
Biden's basically a Republican that's
why they are doing this and everybody
should be criticized for it that is
absolute idiocy and it's time for people
to pull up their big boy pants and
understand what's actually going on here
come on with me let's let's take a
journey so first and foremost what
actually happened over the last 24 48
hours a couple different things number
one the New York Times reports that
former Republican president George
is not going to support the re-election
of Trump this doesn't mean that he's
going to vote for Joe Biden and in his
defense a spokesman for Bush is saying
the report is wrong George W Bush is
steering clear of politics which quite
frankly is a coy way of saying he's not
supporting Trump he may just not be
getting involved whatsoever but that is
where the George W Bush situation stands
as of right now not really a denial that
George W Bush doesn't support Trump but
simply just saying he's not in getting
involved in politics right now a Bush's
brother Jeb Bush the former Republican
governor of Florida he says he's not
sure who he's going to vote for Mitt
Romney current Republican senator from
Utah will not endorse Trump uh and was
by the way Mitt Romney yesterday out
with protestors in Washington DC saying
a black lives matter neither will late
Senator John McCain's wife Cindy McCain
she will not be supporting Donald Trump
and here's Colin Powell yesterday on CNN
straight up telling Jake Tapper he's
voting for Joe Biden and so we're not a
country of just a president we have a
Congress we have a Supreme Court but
most of all we have the people of the
United States the ones who vote the ones
who vote him in and the ones who vote
him out
I couldn't vote for him in 96 and I
certainly cannot in any way support
President Trump this year so yeah I know
you didn't vote for him in 2016 I assume
based on the fact that you approved Joe
Biden when senator then-senator Obama
picked him to be his running mate in
2008 I assume you're going to be voting
for Joe Biden I'm very close to Joe
Biden in a social matter and on a
political matter I've worked with him
for 35 40 years and he is now the
candidate and I will be voting for him
so the reactions from some who have been
writing to me have been war criminal :
Powell is voting for Biden - war
criminals no surprise or Republicans are
voting for Biden because Biden's
basically a Republican this is an
indictment of Joe Biden now you can
dislike Joe Biden you can
choose not to vote for Joe Biden but the
bad takes about this are really painful
like its cringe-worthy to watch
you've got people on the left in the
face of Republicans abandoning their own
party for what they see is the good of
the country and the people on the left
that are writing to me are criticizing
these Republicans and criticizing Joe
Biden come on guys you're looking
foolish for years we've been saying
wouldn't it be great if some Republicans
did what's right for the country instead
of just checking the party orthodoxy and
that's exactly what they are doing here
the better analysis is they are so
disgusted by what Donald Trump is doing
that lifelong Republicans are saying I
can't stand with my party I can't
actually just go with the party
orthodoxy I'm going to have to support
someone else who I would normally never
support never mind publicly admitting it
and you know reminder Bush spokesman is
denying this anyway we don't know what's
going on with George Bush but it doesn't
matter certainly as far as : powell goes
and mit romney this should be viewed as
a good thing a Democratic candidate in
the face of absolute totalitarian Donald
Trump is a reasonable enough diplomat
that lifelong Republicans are okay
saying this time around I can't just
check the box that my party wants me to
check I'm not with the lunatics like Ted
Cruz I'm not with you know Tom cotton
and these whack jobs I am going to think
for myself and do what I see is good for
the country it should be applauded that
they're doing this now it's also a
really bad example of post facto
rationalization by some on the Left who
are now coming up with these criticisms
if Bernie convinced some Republicans to
vote for him it would be rightly cheered
if Biden does it it's because Biden is a
Republican come on guys give me a break
these guys are conservatives they're not
fascists so they aren't going to support
a president taking the country down a
very dark path and that's
supposed to be an indictment of Biden
now of course at the same time it's
still true that Biden is no progressive
Biden is a totally standard center-left
Democrat he wants a $15 minimum wage his
health care proposal would give about 30
million people
additionally health care Trump's would
take it away from about 24 to 32 million
Biden supports the green New Deal as a
framework his tax program is better than
Trump's etc okay he's a center-left
Republican now meanwhile Democrats don't
need to celebrate these endorsements if
they don't want to right let some
right-wingers see that Mitt Romney is
saying no to Trump see that : Powell is
saying no to Trump let them evaluate
what that means for how they're going to
vote and meanwhile Joe Biden can just
keep running his campaign
we're not whitewashing the records of
these Republicans these Republicans can
be horrible people who govern terribly
and are just making one correct decision
here right that it that's all it has to
be and quite frankly the second that a
Democrat is elected to president these
guys likely won't be our allies anymore
we simply agree that Trump is such a
systemic danger that must be removed
that they can't vote for him just
because there's an R next to his name
and that should be applauded that should
be applauded meanwhile we'll go right
back to arguing about taxes and foreign
policy and the entire thing as soon as
Donald Trump is removed then a
Democratic president takes over we are
fighting a proto-fascist here
don't miss the forest for the trees I'm
ready for your disagreements I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman I look forward to
hearing from you remember to sign up for
free to get the daily David Pakman show
audio podcast on iTunes stitcher Spotify
Pandora Google Play podcast whatever
your favorite podcasting software is get
the daily audio podcast if you prefer
that to youtube clips as an example let
me know your thoughts about these
Republican abandonments of Trump on
Twitter where you can find me at D
Pakman
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you I took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what I needed I often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and I've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all helix mattresses come
with a 10 year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
I think you will all of my viewers will
get up to two hundred dollars off your
order and you'll get two super premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video